to navigate there's two things you need
to know the first is where the hell are
you exactly precisely right razorsharp
what's good about you and what's bad
about you by your own by your own
reckoning you don't have to you can ask
other people but this is a game you play
yourself it's like as far as I'm
concerned I'm taking star what is it
that's okay about me and what needs some
work and you got to watch to not be too
self-critical when you're doing that too
because that can just be another kind of
flaw and then the next is okay well
where are you going what's your
destination well and that's what the
frame is now you know you could do that
in a very sophisticated way and you do
that by thinking consciously about who
it is that you are in an articulated
manner and where you want to go and why
and how you're going to get there and
people hardly ever do that that is
that's come as such an absolute shock to
me as an educator I just because one of
the other programs
I use this in my classes what are the
other programs in this suite of programs
is called the Future authoring program
and I started developing it my maps of
meaning class which is where some of
this materials from and I got students
to write about their pasts it's like
okay we're talking about stories so
let's tell your story who are you how do
you get here and what are you now that
usually helps people put things to rest
although it's quite stressful well
you're doing it stress goes up when
you're doing it and maybe you feel
miserable for a couple of weeks and then
stress goes down and it stays down so
that's and that's also why people don't
do it because who the hell wants to have
their stress go up but if it's temporary
it's a sacrifice so then the next issue
is well where are you going and one of
the things that and this I just still I
cannot understand is students that had
been in education system for 15 years 14
years high end students most of them not
once in their whole bloody life did
anyone ever get them to sit down for
like a day and say all right justify
your existence like well seriously it's
like here you are in university you're
taking a bunch of courses you've got
some sort of vague career plan it's like
defend the damn thing a bit since you're
gonna go live it and everything you're
taking everything on it it's like what's
your damn plan and why are you so
convinced that it's not the plan of a
babbling fool because if you haven't
thought about it then it is and if you
really want to go out there and live
that out you know one of the things Carl
Jung said was that you you're in a story
whether you know it or not and and then
he made two nice comments about that if
it's someone else's story you're
probably going to get a bit part and it
might not be the one you want and if
it's a story that you don't know it
might be one with a really bad ending or
maybe it's just bad period with a worse
ending and if you don't know what this
story that you're living out is maybe
that's the one you know maybe you got
that from your mother you got it from
your grandmother you got it from your
aunt or god only knows where you picked
it up because you pick up things like
mad because that's what human beings are
like so maybe you're living a malevolent
tragedy unconsciously and then one thing
you might ask yourself is well how
wretched and miserable is your life
let's add a few tile to that how
wretched miserable and futile is your
life and you might say well yeah seventy
percent on each count it's like then
you're probably unconsciously living out
a malevolent tragedy and maybe that's
not for the best
oh it's either that or the whole
universe hates you right or 70 percent
hates you you know so so anyways you
know we got students to start writing in
detail about it's not what they wanted
it's not a career thing because that's
the closest people usually get is they
have a career plan it's like no no it's
not a career plan that's that's
peripheral important but peripheral it's
like alright you got three years man
you're gonna live them anyways devote
those three years to setting the world
up around you so that it's the best it
could possibly be for you as if you were
taking care of yourself as if you cared
for yourself well what would that look
like
you know let's say just for the sake of
argument if you figured out where you
were that you could have what would be
best for you well what is that I bet you
never asked people don't ask and
so life comes out them like random
snakes and they sort of fend them off
and life goes by and things don't work
out the way people expected them to but
a huge part of that is they didn't know
where they were because they wouldn't
look or didn't know that they should
look ignorant and willful blindness
right two great catastrophes and they
never figured out where they wanted to
go or why now there's a problem with
figure out where you want to go and the
problem is is that you make your
conditions for failure clear to yourself
and people don't like that so if you
keep yourself in the fog then you can't
tell when you screwed up now that isn't
so good because you're still screwing up
you're just too blind self blind to
notice although in in the short term
that's less painful if you make your
criteria for success razor sharp then
you know every time you screw up but
that's great because then you could fix
it you could either repair the the the
behavioral inadequacy or the conceptual
inadequacy that you're using as a tool
in that situation or maybe you could
adjust your dam plan either way you can
fix it and so okay so you're living in
one of these bloody things and you might
as well it seems to me you might as well
make it the best one you could live in
because you don't have anything better
to do now if you don't do that if you
don't do it consciously and this is what
the psychoanalyst pointed out is that
you have innumerable quasi autonomous
subsystems that make you up that will
generate stories impulsively and you'll
just act them out and you know that
because you watch yourself over two
weeks and you think Jesus I did a lot of
stupid things in the last two weeks and
you think why and it's because you're a
random you're a collection of somewhat
random quasi autonomous personality
units and lacking a leader they're just
gonna fire off whenever they want you
know first you're hungry then you're
thirsty then you want to go to bed with
your wife you know then you want to
sleep in then you want to tell your boss
off and you want to curse at the guy
that cuts you off in traffic it's like
you're kind of like a two-year-old
you know just it's one emotional frame
there another vying for dominance
there's no overarching hierarchy and
there's no king at the top